we're told that a conservationist has
the hypothesis that when squirrels are
more crowded together they have higher
rates of aggression
the table below shows the area of three
parks and the number of squirrels in
each that's given right over here order
the parks from least crowded to most
crowded
based on the crowdedness in which park
would the conservationist expect to see
the highest rate of aggression
so pause this video and see if you can
figure this out
all right now let's work through this
together so we want to order the parks
from least crowded to most crowded so
how can we think about crowded well we
could think about it in terms of the
number of squirrels
squirrels
per
area per hectare
and so something with a lot of squirrels
per hectare would be more crowded and
something with fewer squirrels per
hectare would be less crowded you could
also if you wanted to think about it in
terms of hectares per squirrel this
would also be a legitimate way of
tackling it and of course if you have
more hectares per squirrel that would be
less crowded it'd be the other way
around while if you had fewer hectares
per squirrel it would be more crowded
but here when we look at this the
numbers of squirrels are larger than the
number of hectares in every scenario so
it might be a little bit easier to
divide in this one and this is also how
my brain tends to think about it so
let's calculate the number of squirrels
per hectare for each of these parks
so first of all let's think about park a
and i will do that over here park a
you have 54
squirrels i'll write s
all right squ for short
per every eight
hectares and so this is going to be the
same thing as 54 over 8 squirrels
per
hectare
and we could try to estimate it but it
looks like they are all actually a
little bit around
seven if we divide the number of
squirrels by the number of hectares so
we have to might get a little we might
have to get a little bit more precise so
let's see eight goes into 54. i will do
it over here eight goes into 54.
it goes
6 times 6 times 8 is 48 and i subtract i
get a remainder of 6 and then let me put
a little decimal here
and then if i bring down that 0 8 goes
into 60
7 times 7 times 8 is 56
and i can keep going but let me see if
this is enough precision for me to
compare so this is part a is
approximately i'll make this little
squiggle here for approximately
6.7 squirrels
per
hectare
now let me do park b right over here so
for park b we have 20 squirrels squu for
short for every 2.7
hectares now one thing we can do to help
simplify this so we don't have to deal
with decimals is let's multiply both the
numerator and the denominator by 10
notice that's just equivalent to
multiplying by one so this is equivalent
to saying you have
200 squirrels
for every
hectares
or you could view it as 200 over 27
squirrels per hectare so let's take 27
into
and if i were to estimate it let's see
27 is close to 30
30 would go into 200
six times let me try that out so it goes
into 200 6 times
6 times 7 is 42
6 times 2 is 12 plus 4 is 16
and then if i subtract
i am going to actually get looks like 38
so maybe i can fit in
one more 27 there so let me do that 7.
so 7 times 7 is 49
49 7 times 2 is 14
plus 4 is 18. yup that worked out nicely
if you subtract 189 from 200 you're
going to get 11. and now let me bring
down a zero
so how many times does 27 go into a
hundred and ten
well it looks like it goes three times i
think three times seven is twenty-one
three times two is six plus two is
eight
and it looks like actually i could fit
in one more so let's see it might go
four times
so 110
so if i go four times four times seven
is 28
and then 4 times 2 is
8 plus 2 is 10. yeah it went
4 times so get a remainder of 2. so we
could keep going but this is
approximately 7.4 so approximately 7.4
squirrels
per hectare so we already see that park
b is more crowded than park a but now
let's check out park c
and so for park c
we have 51
squirrels
for every
6.8 hectares 6.8 hectares
so we could do the same idea let's
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by 10 which means that we
have 510 squirrels
for
every
68 hectares
and so 68 will go into
510 i'm guessing i'm going to have to
have some decimals here so it's close to
70 70 would go into 510
about seven times let me see how that
works out 7 times 8 is 56
7 times 6 is 42 plus 5 is 47 and i think
i did well there
so if i subtract here i could do some
regrouping or i could try to do it in my
head to go from 476 to 500 i would have
to add 24 plus another 10. so i'm going
to have 34
right over here
bring down a zero
and so if i'm thinking roughly 70 goes
into
340. let's see will it go
it might go five times actually let me
try that out if i say 7.5 5 times 8 is
and then 5 times 6 is 30 plus 4 it went
exactly 5 times
so that means in part c we're at 7.5
squirrels
per hectare
so what's the most crowded or if i
wanted to order it well the most crowded
is park c the second crowded is park b
and the third most crowded is park a and
so based on crowdedness in which park
would i expect the highest rate of
aggression well park c the squirrels are
all they're much closer to each other
they might be fighting over things who
knows but there we go we answered the
question